[Musique]
clément marie bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le président du ceto sma le comité
territorial olympique et sportif de
martinique vous avez été élu donc à la
présidence en septembre dernier mais
vous avez un long passé de dirigeant
sportif as diverti d'ailleurs donc vous
connaissez bien le monde associatif
sportif en tant que président du ceto
sma est pas dans les années passées
clément marie est ce que vous avez
entretenu des relations avec les éditer
des diverses municipalités et avec les
responsables des communautés
d'agglomération voix titre personnel
est-ce que voilà c'est des gens que vous
voyez régulièrement que je vais pas dire
vous fréquentez mais enfin bon alors je
fais mieux pense en deux volets la
première c'est que j'ai quand même les
relations j'ai donc privilégié avec le
pratiquement tous les maires de deux
autres des 34 communes
je gérais ne sont pas amis on se voit
pas tous les jours mais j'ai des
relations jeudi et cordiales avec
pratiquement tous les maires de toutes
les communes tant que ça c'est la 1ère
partie la deuxième partie c'est que dans
le cadre de ma présidence de la za
tropiques association des sports
automobiles
je suis je rappelle que je suis
président depuis depuis 2009
vous n'êtes encore je suis toujours
s'effectuer je crois que j'ai des
relations privilégiées avec les maires
des communes sur lesquelles nous
organisons des manifestations
il s'agit donc soit de cozycot soit des
rallyes des rallyes régionaux dont sur
la vie de cette paris on va nommer
régulièrement avec le maire actuel et
qui a pris la relève de celui que
j'étais avant lui donc il ya eu
nous sommes entrain de 7e rallye que
nous organisons cette commune et puis
aussi avec d'autres communes sur
lesquelles nous faisons des cous de cote
comme avant ce soir je verrai ça se
passe bien en général ça se passe bien
est ce que les maires acceptent
volontiers qui dit est justement des
manifestations sportives
alors plus ou moins faciles organisée là
vous parlez sport automobile il ya des
manifestations qui sont peut-être plus
facile à organiser qui nécessite moins
de sécurité - autorisation voyez ce que
je sais ce que vous dites
puisqu'aujourd'hui aussi à l'enjeu les
premières obligations oui ça se passe
bien
si on continue et on fait des éditions
qui chauffe émules dans le temps c'est
parce qu'il ya quand même une volonté
municipale de pouvoir les organiser sans
quoi ce serait partant et puis et puis
la deux la deuxième est pas ce serait de
dire que effectivement ça devient de
plus en plus difficiles à organiser les
manifestations parce que en ce qui
concerne le sport automobile comme les
courses pédestres les concepteurs il ya
une mise en place du cdr s'appelle
commission départementale de sécurité
routière qui automatiquement valide donc
la faisabilité en prenant en compte
toutes les mesures de sécurité
les mesures concernant pratiquement
toute organisation et surtout les
mesures qui sont prises concernant
d'autres les secours il faut aujourd'hui
nobila soit dotée de tous les éléments
que le médecin qui suit la compétition
soit pratiquement urgentiste c'est tout
parle de choses que je connais que je
vis au quotidien
donc je peux croire au vu pour organiser
une manifestation c'est vrai que c'est
pas évident et puis à la responsabilité
de ce livre organisé au sol aussi
responsabilité de la menace que j'avais
bien mettre en place divers il nous
donne son accord et qui justement a
donné son accord fait confiance à
l'organisateur alors le ceto sma donc le
comité territorial olympique et sportif
de martinique à bien des missions
évidemment des missions de détection des
missions de mise en place de bonnes
conditions de du développement de la
pratique sportive sur notre territoire
et est ce que le ceto sma dans ses
relations avec les différents organismes
politiques les opci les municipalités
est-ce que ça va jusqu'à avoir établir
des partenariats
mettre en place des conventions pour tel
ou tel objectif at home votre question
j'ai l'impression que vous avez lu dans
mon programme puisque c'est exactement
ce que j 7 développé depuis que j'ai été
vite donc c'est à la fatalité de mes
deux coups décision le 9 9 septembre
2019 rappelle que le comité qui est mis
en place qui fonctionne vous dis avait
été dès le 9 avril 2018
il n'y a pas de 6000 étudiants 10
minutes il n'y a pas l'argent il se
trouve que lille devait première action
a été de décrire aux 3 epic et de leur
demande et donc de me recevoir j'étais
au support la cap nau directeur de cap
nau et g/t au / sipa le président thein
non je l'appelle là non parce que c'est
un achat - ça c'est mon ami et mon ami
personnel
le président la case et lectures de
cabinet est aussi son directeur des
services des services et pour leur
présenter donc une demande qui est et
qui correspondait donc j'avais fait un
diagnostic qui qui me paraissaient
alarmant concernant les infrastructures
qui sont sous les communes concernant
les deux chaque épicerie de l'opération
deux autres vaccins sur les 100 et
généraux et demander de quelles mesures
pourraient aider les municipalités à
entretenir ou réparer donc les des
prostituées qui sont son défunt pour
vous dire par exemple on va parler du
saint joseph puisque ce que je lui ai
parlé
ayant à l'esprit cool si jamais il ya au
fait du sport et puis que vous avez des
sportifs qui glisse et bien c'est de la
responsabilité civile du maire de la
commune du gua et que vous êtes on est
en plein champ sur la question et il va
utile de le rappeler
erding se marie vous ne savez même pas
ce qui vous attend parce que le stade de
saint joseph effectivement n'est pas au
nom donc on a pas de lumière
effectivement le plus important mais il
se trouve que les tribunes je vais les
fermer parce que je n'ai pas les moyens
de réparer je les dis chaussures nommé
gains et c'est le cas dans d'autres
communes aussi
enfin joseph mai
à commencer de réparation et se termine
à une hausse est particulièrement le
dieu qui est inquiétant on va dire ça
comme ça c'est la commune de ducos qui
avale d'espacés fermés depuis des années
et comme j'ai eu pendant de bois je veux
dire la municipalité a touché des
souvenirs et par le redressement et à la
date de woody n'ont pas fait les
réparations
je sais pas comment vous pouvez le dire
le maire ne se représente pas un autre
je ne sais pas comment celui qui va
prendre la suite va faire pour embaucher
les 400 vidéos qui vont qui doivent être
remboursés parce que les travaux n'ont
pas été fait et il veut il se trouve que
c'est arrivé à un tiers de l'utilisation
de l'argent
vous avez compris qu'ils viennent me
voir je suis prêt à répondre de ce que
je dis pourquoi je dis ça c'est pas se
veut une association qui fait du du
handball et c du corps ce qui
aujourd'hui à plus de 350 licenciés et
cette association quand elle reçoit
quand elle reçoit jeudi bien donc de ce
championnat prénational d'une des quatre
équipes b aux équipes au mondial est
obligé d'aller recevoir au mon âge on a
sept maris vous comprenez bien il est de
mon devoir de défendre donc la situation
actuelle donc la 2d et factures et si
vous me permettez d'ajouter qu' on a été
plus loin
vous avez décidé à mon prédécesseur par
exemple permis chômage y avait pris
contact avec le bailleur social va par
le nommer qui donc est prêt à mettre ses
effets surtout à notre disposition avec
la ctm sommes en train de mettre en
place d'une convention qui va être signé
ils vont réparer des infrastructures qui
vont être mises à disposition il s'agit
de terrains de deux salles d'intérêt de
terrain de basket et nous avons eu notre
partenariat qui va se mettre en place
avec les collèges et les lycées
il s'agit donc de faire une convention
de la septième avec des proviseurs et
les principaux et nous allons donc
mettre en place aussi
on va d'une cartographie de tous ces
éléments qui vont revenir donc au niveau
de délégués des comités pour dire voilà
on dit vous pouvez faire une extension
de votre de vous de votre discipline
dans le cadre de l' exemple de de
l'athlétisme de le cadre du football du
handball de l'escrimé et 6,59 faire et
puis nous avons aussi nous pencher en 2e
3e toi sur la situation
cette fois-ci retour il se trouve dans
les combles alors clément marie très
rapidement est ce que vous estimez qu'il
ya suffisamment de pas seulement de
pratiquants mais de dirigeant sportif
aussi qu'ils s'impliquent dans la
citoyenneté et notamment la vie
politique qui en est en tête de liste
aux policiers est ce qu'il faudrait
qu'il y en ait davantage qui porte la
parole un petit peu justement de la
pratique sportive à ce niveau là en
quelques mois parce que notre situation
c'est une bonne question mais il se
trouve que pourriez prendre je veux
encore parler de mon expérience
personnelle je dis qu on peut pas faire
les deux on peut être militant
associatif bénévole mais ça peut servir
de ton plus pouvoir faire de la
politique mais même de mon cas présent
moi j'ai choisi parce que je suis
passionné de la vie associative de faire
de la vie associative
parce que je sais que la vivre la vie
politique elle est allée aux
compilations souvent on amène à l'autre
dans en sens inverse en forme mais
pratiquer les 200 cafés les deux pour
moi c'est pas une bonne chose mais ma
qu'il arrive à le faire mais tôt ou tard
ils prennent des coups de bâton et quand
on a des responsabilités associatives on
ne peut pas à mon avis être au niveau au
niveau politique
quelle est votre principale attente
clément marie en tant que président du
ceto sma pour les prochaines années
puisque là il ya les municipales et
communautaires mais on sait que l'année
prochaine il y aura les territoriales
qu'est-ce que quel est votre voeu à
l'aube on veut aujourd'hui je veux pas
vous mentir on a commencé déjà fait des
petits travaux parce que c'est elle nous
a aidés à nous donner une petite une
petite somme il peut toujours ce qui va
nous aider à aa à boucher les trous
donc la maison des sports a été réalisée
en 87 prendre des décisions aujourd'hui
33 ans je suis vraiment vibrer cette
maison augmenter le nombre de saints et
aussi donner la possibilité à cet outil
puisque le terrain et la maison actuelle
les murs actuels appartiennent donc
cette hausse c'était le un legs de nos
prix décision je parle au maire comment
le sergent joseph et c est bien ce
serait mon vélo pupilles un jouet
souhaité que ce soit aidée par la
nouvelle la nouvelle du 10 gestes de les
dirigeants de la city mais aussi par les
collectivités qui qui vont avoir un
outil à mon avis les informant pour
pouvoir corriger le soir nous occuper de
2,62 ligues et comités qui sont toujours
essayé au sol il y en a partout et le
siège se trouve sur le territoire de la
ville de fort de france et ex cet
exemple de la vierge c'est ça ils vont
se laisser duper par voie il faut
entamer j'attends vraiment que ça se
fasse merci clément marie d'avoir
participé à ce qu'a dit réalisé par
patrice à la guise à la chine
[Musique]